go Andrew my name welcome back to some
more happy wheels uh uh goodbye quick
let's [ __ ] start with a quiz I can
just accuse my character I guess
fulfilling it would be the best
adventure Segway guy okay I was supposed
to choose
alright let's see how well I know myself
what horror games does pity pie plate in
most is it period BAM penumbra amnesia I
wish you could mod hambre having a good
time penis master ramming sir um what
does Beauty call the golden statue in
amnesia name is Frank just kidding I
thought I was getting come on shake
weight oh come on oh thank god alright
let's go with Devon oh adage was
occurred a blog has did not like that
answer so Ron episode in amnesia was fun
and point whoa whoa right but dude due
to comment here see what this is
question number three it's abduction
barely I knew that excellent I was
worried sick did I give birth to someone
I think I did call you Jeremy what does
peter pan collar subscribers period
there's secret passage I would never
call anyone that called nothing nothing
sorry bro hey what does vide Karla
Sheridan it's such an array dot I should
[ __ ] it call him doctor yet maybe cuz he
look so fancy and all the fat on I've
seen a man was done alright what get
this is difficult I mean I don't see how
sorry that was fly what game still on me
the master you all right what game did
pit by play on this first video we ever
made
well it's actually neither of these and
I don't have my older videos but it was
actually the blacklight tango Down
superb but anyway it was some like hey
what does PewDiePie's say at the start
of his videos howdy hi guys
hi guys let's go with how's it going
bread unbelievable
hey I don't know that is but let's make
a party hey I got them all right I am
that is probably the only map I ever
been good at ever Wiley and ko woody
demo that sounds pretty good
wait for screen please the [ __ ] is this
uh what what no you're shot if I bet you
eat this deck this is something he wants
to shove up his oops I'm sorry but it's
only them ah god damn it that's pretty
cool though stop saying this I agree uh
uh boom no are you no I'm not
our drag dolls survived sounds fantastic
oh no way - that was funny me a nice ass
whoa higher than that oh why are you
then what's your name
alright i'll glide by right down here
like that oh and like my favorite hello
oh I'm still alive not my heart I'm not
alive anymore son of a--
oh my heart it's a cannibal there anyway
there's like this were touchy that I got
you ass [ __ ] oh you're mine oh you're
mine you're so fine used to find your
mind as it's my
dammit he escaped that's all my reg
fiction all right come on we gotta save
myself got up one is leg see if I can no
cannot everybody's giving up I can do a
front-flip stand whoa can I make that a
la na na
all right I can actually do it please
now that's gonna burn that's gonna oh ah
ah ah ah I'm gonna make - [ __ ] make
gives you for last you can ever [ __ ]
buck except you come here I Alex
gangbang oh yeah come here come here
oh come here I broke my ass I never now
is that positive about it
come here leg ah I can't say it but I
want to say it alright Oh legs I don't
like that ou can eat it and hand on my
back come here legs you gotta save me Oh
God yeah my survival instincts are so
good ah that glam glam it's not over
until it's over you know
so many just [ __ ] hand go ha ha ha
you too
ah food I can survive here but maybe I
can diet diet diet diet diet identity
so bad why a myself oh yeah it's gonna
work it's it [ __ ] why go on a lot I
can see you move away though is it
moving super nothing why am I wasting
time on stuff like that I'm sorry
all right let's sit down touch people
feist disgusting
alright so many things insect in
distillates reduce sound about legs
alright I can still do it it's not gonna
stop me abs machetes is a problem though
and what in my [ __ ] head girl that is
impressive
what I'm going back what you you are
pissing me off mister fly don't you are
touching bras are you saying some
secrets to bras I gotta turn on the
lights
ah that was good run all right you bro
suggested this man so let's do it
bye I said I'm scared of being in the
ghetto in the ghetto front flap don't
get that one huh let's do that again all
right bye let's try it again
but Dad you never have a basketball are
you gonna take
we are just watch duct ha ha ha [ __ ]
yeah that's how I roll you see this [ __ ]
bar you share that [ __ ] [ __ ] did I just
help my son to death [ __ ] yeah whoa wha
ah by Gaza I love you bye
that's [ __ ] awesome holy Shay let's
try that again
[ __ ] me we are doing this [ __ ] I got da
da da barrel
god damn it one boy drive a gun - I love
you I want to be with you alright here
we go
judge gets me yeah [ __ ] yeah ah good I
did I hated doing that I thought it come
to you it's just [ __ ] stay there you
decide of me of you
disappoints me alright you say this [ __ ]
by you will never be as hardcore as I am
but I'm sorry about everything
I shut up Jesus guys I'm coming over to
kill you I love you I would you can you
can I dance alright alright that's
impressing I didn't know why I'm a
recounts add sugar i dad i chair go
can't even [ __ ] skirt all right son
I'll let you two score this one go son
don't gotcha
did you see that how are you go note my
penis is stuck we're done bum no that's
not your penis come on
am I better to stop what the [ __ ] bro
what the [ __ ] huh stupid basketball
[ __ ] hi last one I'm sorry aleef
unnie mad all right let's go [ __ ] am i
doing [ __ ] far away
ah ah ah
alrighty and then push him forward
somehow are you ready for this boy yeah
go lay come on man I'm wasting time here
let's go let's go let's go let's go Wow
come on I want one good I want a good
when I got I'm ready for this I'm super
pumped go son what goddamn disgrace
[ __ ] hate you
alright I was get a dunk good times
alright we are back I realized I my disc
phase ran out of memory so I didn't have
my thing else there was a little short
video so I wanted to continue are you a
pro dogger much time all right here we
go
I let it happen
gotta let my feet oh [ __ ] heal oh my
god that was awesome alright in my
[ __ ]
God doesn't even matter alright right
five if you kill her back up yeah cough
I got you right by your teeth girl right
oh I got her head batch I got your [ __ ]
head up she's giving oh I don't know
what she's doing now dancing maybe you
suck at dancing girl best but look at
this lady should I do I know how to
dance let's give her touch your butt I
don't [ __ ] know cut don't go closer
don't go
so I died I got your foot at least your
axe tastes pretty good
ah no way she's panicking me no ah [ __ ]
oh no don't touch Vespa what am i doing
let's run mine throw it sorry you got
man well done lady oh you lost your arm
though what are you doing trying to
climb Vespa you don't climb bet what is
gonna know yeah got a break 3-1 my throw
it crap crap down why hang up
let's guess ting lay down Shh Oh Shh
you're dead oh just calm down
you're dead okay what's your head doing
your head is not supposed to dance you
know that I kill his man rabbit I can't
have a done ah yes take the shard in
your fridge now hey looks good on me
looks like I have a big penis yay what
are you doing killing yourself woman
don't copy me I can only kill myself
here one let's try kill yourself ah I I
got your head back nah that's how I roll
woah woah I'm Greg great okay take your
head whatever you want I don't what just
let me go ah stabbing [ __ ] God
uh happy wheels in a nutshell
alright I will have to be it have rules
so slow right now but anyway
blackberries you enjoyed us subscribe to
come wretched a on scene accepts Arab
army sound
I just got to get up here
all right eject said then immediately
hold up all right [ __ ] what a bad job